on en parle avec nos invités ils sont en
direct avec nous jean-marc chipeau porte
parole debout la france et françois
gratton si les médecins spécialistes de
santé publique bonjour messieurs
un nouvelle mobilisation jean-marc
chipeau ce samedi alors que le pass
anita est entrée en vigueur depuis ce
lundi qu'est ce que vous en attendez de
ca manifestations mais écoutez il faut
absolument faire fléchir le gouvernement
et le ramener à la raison on avait vu
dans les drapeaux qui était derrière
vous reporter que cette colère en fait
agréer j'ai tout un tas de tout un tas
de personnes encore vous n'avez montré
qu'un sale qu'un seul rassemblement ce
que l'on constate c'est que vous avez
des personnes de toute extraction
sociale de toutes origines qui
manifestent parce qu'elle se sente visé
directement par les propos du président
de la république qui les rend
responsables de la situation actuelle
tout le monde constate que ce pass
sanitaire est une grave atteinte à des
droits fondamentaux sains naturels
constitutionnel et à prescriptibles des
citoyens tout le monde parlait du tout
le monde c'est le conseil d'état le
conseil constitutionnel la commission
mixte paritaire la cnil tous les
organismes qui ont été consultés dans
l'élaboration de ce projet le mans ont
tous fait ce même constat ils ont
simplement considéré que le projet de
loi présenté des exigences de santé
publique qui allait au dessus de tout ça
et je suis désolé mais ça ne passe pas
nous nous sommes en profond désaccord
avec ça nous estimons que les valeurs
cardinales de la république que sont la
liberté l'égalité la fraternité sont au
dessus de tout le reste est que toutes
les lois doivent se plier à 7
exigeant pas cette exigence là d'autant
plus qu'aujourd'hui on se rend compte
que l'objectif du gouvernement de
parvenir une immunité collective
s'éloigne de plus en plus alors nous
sommes en direct avec un médecin
monsieur crasneanscki expliquez nous
pourquoi
à l'heure actuelle le pass année terre
est une nécessité selon vous pour la
france
c'est une nécessité
je sais pas en tout cas c'est un outil
qui dans je le rappelle une situation de
crise sanitaire est aujourd'hui
intéressant 1
encore une fois si on avait atteint
l'immunité collective ou du moins des
taux de vaccination supérieur à 70%
voisinant les 80%
ce dont je ne doute pas que nous
puissions arriver dans les prochains
mois on aurait matt a besoin de ces
outils finalement qui pour un peu un peu
poussé à pousser en tout cas favoriser
un site et de façon un peu voilà un peu
on peut pousser la vaccination je
voulais rebondir sur une chose parce que
tout le monde ne tourne dit tout le
monde constate que le ca
atteint aux libertés etc
il ya tout de même un sondage est là qui
est sorti cette semaine qui a montré que
80% des personnes interrogées se
disaient favorables au dispositif
alors faut faire attention entre les
personnes qui se font le plus voir ou
entendre mais qui représente tout de
même une minorité et les personnes qui
sont favorables au dispositif ou à
aujourd'hui l'objectif et ça je pense
que j'espère en tout cas que même les
manifestants de partage c'est de sauver
des vies c'est de sortir de la crise de
retrouver une vie normale donc après on
peut être d'accord ou pas avec certaines
mesures là tout ce qu'on peut dire c'est
que la vaccination c'est le meilleur
outil qu'on a sur le plan sanitaire pour
sortir de la crise qui eu besoin quelque
part de se passer ni terre pour pousser
un peu la vaccination et d'autre part à
côté continuer à faire tourner
l'économie qui est aussi un facteur de
santé extrêmement important à plus long
terme
voilà on aurait peut-être pu s'en passer
si on avait eu un taux de vaccination
est extrêmement important durant l'été
maintenant la vaccination se poursuit on
a dépassé les 50% de vaccination de
personnes totalement vacciner les
vaccinations continue espérons que dans
un mois dans deux mois et bien on est
plus besoin du pass sanitaire qui est
suffisamment de vacciner que les
chiffres baissent que le voilà et que la
tensions hospitalières diminue et dans
ce cas d'accord sur le plan de la
liberté c'est beaucoup l'ont déjà dit
mais où jusqu'où va la liberté
individuelle et la responsabilité une
personne qui ait infecté qui refusent de
se faire vacciner qui je sais pas
rentrer dans un ehpad et puis créer un
cluster ou et sa part de responsabilité
donc là sur le plan sanitaire il ya un
vrai débat
voilà moi je pense qu'il faut tout de
même se dire qu'il ya une part de
protection qui est importante c'est
qu'il faut garder en tête jean-marc si
peu vous êtes porte-parole ans d'un
parti politique debout la france que
propose autres partis pour freiner la
propagation de ce virus sont à 100
appliquer le pass annie terre
mais le passé ni terme pardonnez moi
parce sanitaire n'a qu'un seul but c'est
le but de de lisser la courbe d entrée à
l'hôpital et ça on paye on paie le prix
d'une politique qui passe de 20 ans et
qui a été accentuée par le gouvernement
mâcon on continue de fermer des lits
faut savoir que alors on part on
continue de fermer des lits pourquoi ce
que je dis toujours c'est que si on
voulait sortir d'un faut commencer par
arrêter de creuser un trou et je suis
désolé le passe à lithaire ne doit pas
servir de prétexte pour continuer à
faire des économies budgétaires sur le
dos de la santé ça c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose c'est que la
vaccination ne n'empêche pas la
transmission elle a ralenti mais elle ne
l'empêchent pas et donc vous avez
peut-être personnes vaccinées qui sont
contaminante et auquel on a dit vous
pouvez enlever romas vous pouvez vivre à
votre vie notre tranquillement donc je
suis même se passe ça ne mène nulle part
il ne sert il ne sert à rien on est
peut-être les choses en revanche il faut
effectivement maintenir les gestes les
gestes barrières notamment le port du
masque en intérieur ça c'est fondamental
il faut recourir à la peau tests
préventifs l'alcool y vivent a décrété
une manière administrative que le virus
ne devait pas se déclarer dans un délai
de 72 heures les 48 heures tu n'as les
rançons administratives qui font le
reste c'est totalement incohérent on
sait très bien qu'en agissant de la
sorte on va créer des faux négatifs donc
il faut à un moment donné reprendre une
politique de bon sens c'est-à-dire 1 on
respecte les gestes barrière la
vaccination c'est du bénéfice-risque m
toute l'essence même de n'importe quelle
politique de vaccination c'est le
bénéfice-risque sais rien donc les
personnes fragiles doivent se faire va
se faire vacciner si le bénéfice est
plus important aux touristes et ensuite
il faut bien évidemment renforcé les cas
des capacités hospitalières et puis
pardon mais qu'est ce qui nous dit
delfraissy boudina nouveaux variants qui
va arriver à l'automne je passais ma
boule de cristal et qu'est ce qu'on fait
c'est invariant plus virulent est plus
contagieux que l'arrivée sans lequel le
vaccin actuel mail est inopérant on est
exactement dans la même situation qu'eux
seuls dans laquelle nous étions mois de
janvier 2020 françois comment ce qui
vous vous êtes donc je le répète en êtes
médecin on parlait justement de la
situation des hôpitaux et on parle
beaucoup aujourd'hui de celle des
hôpitaux aux antilles est ce que c'est
un scénario qui pourrait arriver en
métropole où est ce qu'on est on en est
encore loin
alors je vais pas me projeter sur les
scénarios de ces comme l'a dit comme l'a
dit la personne qui est en face de vous
virtuellement
pas possible d'avoir une boule de
cristal et ça depuis deux ans on l'a
bien vu il ya plein de choses qu'on ne
peut pas anticiper la seule différence
qu'il ya entre les antilles et
malheureusement et la métropole c'est
que eux ils ont un couverture d'une
couverture vaccinale qui est on peut le
dire un trop faible qui est autour de
20% alors à augmenter un peu
dernièrement mais alors que nous on est
on commence à avoir une couverture
nationale qui est qui et qui autour des
50% qui vient de dépasser donc sur les
personnes fragiles qui sont elles sont
là aujourd'hui très majoritairement
vacciner entre 80 et 95 % pour les
personnes les plus âgées puisque
c'étaient les personnes qui ont été
ciblés prioritairement par la campagne
vaccinale donc on a un bon taux de
couverture maintenant à 1
comment dire à fort taux de population
fin de beaucoup de personnes qui sont
entre 30 et 50 ans qui sont en train
d'être vaccinées en termes de volume
c'est donc demande c'est les personnes
qui sont les plus vacciner mais en
termes de taux de pourcentage savait pas
encore mais on sent que c'est en train
d'augmenter donc aujourd'hui ce qu'on
peut dire c'est que même si invariants
aujourd'hui surtout les variants qui ont
émergé on a vu que la vaccination elle
avait tout de même une efficacité qui
était quand même importante donc
aujourd'hui l'objectif c'est que si on
est suffisamment vacciner on casse les
chaînes de transe de transmission entre
les personnes et c'est ça qui va faire
10 hué et possiblement faire disparaître
en grande majorité
les virus les gestes barrières bien sûr
c'est une protection complémentaire
encore une fois le vaccin c'est pas un
bouclier ultime au co vide ni
individuellement ni collectivement
malheureusement mais en tout cas c'est
la meilleure arme qu'on aie ca combiné
aux gestes barrières on a des on a des
raisons de penser que ça va quand même
avoir un impact très favorable et nous
permettre de retrouver une vie normale
mais surtout et encore une fois de
diminuer le nombre de cas graves et de
décès donc là on est on est on va voir
dans les prochaines semaines je pense
l'impact de là on voit des gens en terme
de population qui est pas tout à fait la
même et en termes de répercussion c'est
pas tout à fait les mêmes choses que les
vagues précédentes on va voir si en
effet il ya aussi - das pitt alisation
réanimation par exemple même si c'est un
indicateur qu'il faut relativiser mais
surtout moins de décès voilà et -2 -2 4
très grave donc en tout cas on semble
aller dans la dans la bonne voie
maintenant je pense qu'il faut vraiment
persister et et accentuer le accentue l
pas jean marc flipo qui voyait hocher la
tête qu'est ce que vous répondez à
monsieur crabe en ski je répète que
spécialiste de santé publique
mais enfin je suis désolé quand vous
avez si je reprends les chiffres du
président de la république
vous avez encore prendre pour cent de la
population vaccinée qui est contaminante
vous pouvez pas considérer que la
vaccination soit l'alpha et l'oméga de
tout et vous pouvez pas analysé les
résultats des hospitalisations des décès
et c'est simplement alleaume de la seule
vaccination c'est pas possible je vais
vous montrer à suivre les mêmes cours
aura très rapidement c'est la courbe du
r effective c'est à dire la
contamination la diffusion de la maladie
dans la population vous avez un picot au
20 janvier et au cette hausse et route
on était déjà redescendue à 1,7 et diac
on est vraisemblablement passé sous la
journée sap l'épidémie régresse à
l'heure actuelle dans le dans le pli est
mécaniquement avec un retard de quinze
jours trois semaines un mois c'est
quelque chose qui va se voir aussi dans
les hospitalisations et qui va
naturellement faire baisser de la faire
baisser tout ça donc on peut pas ne peut
pas prendre des chiffres les extraire si
vous sortiez une étude il ya trois
autres études qui vont faire le
contraire moi je suis pas médecin je
suis dans un parti politique et j'essaye
de regarder comment on peut gouverner un
pays sans le mettre sur le flanc sans
créer les castes de sous citoyens et de
faire en sorte que l'on s'en sorte
collectivement il va je suis désolée la
direction qui est prise à l'heure
actuelle par le gouvernement macro qui
consiste à jeter les français les uns
contre les autres a accusé des soignants
qui étaient les héros hier aujourd'hui
on les accuse quasiment d'être des
assassins parce qu'ils vont contaminer
la lors la soi-disant leur patience ils
sont pas vaccinés alors qu'il peut sa
pratique est précisément les gestes
barrières tout ça c'est que c'est une
impasse totale on est obligé quand même
deux
projeter dans l'avenir de ré anticipé de
ré anticiper les choses pour le mieux
car ce qu'on a pu beaucoup de temps
est-ce que vous avez quelque chose à
répondre
oui je le revois je comprends pas bien
tous les propos puisque si on voit un
air qui diminue rapidement sait bien que
c'est la conséquence de quelque chose
donc à priori d'une politique sanitaire
qui a l'air quand même c'est assez
efficace ensuite on a quand même voilà
un nombre d'hospitalisations a vu que
les plus fragiles sont moins touchés
alors que c'étaient les premiers touchés
enfin c'est pas des études prise en
dehors des unes des autres enfin je veux
dire mans alain principe d' analyse bon
sens assez simple qui va maintenant
est-ce qu'on peut pas faire c'est se
projeter dans l'avenir qu'est ce qui va
vraiment arriver puisque on en découvre
un peu tout et tous les jours toutes les
semaines et le souci c'est
qu'aujourd'hui un peu hier ce n'est pas
un souci mais c'est un questionnement
c'est qu'il ya plusieurs catégories
comme j'ai dit à peu près 4 3% qui sont
favorables et qui jouent le jeu de la
solidarité et puis qui espère sortir le
plus rapidement possible de la crise
dans les opposants il y à des partis
politiques et des personnes et des
personnes politiques dont je ne fais pas
partie aujourd'hui et qui utilise la
crainte des oeufs de certaines personnes
pour être en contestation avec le
gouvernement ou un autre parti politique
ça un peu loin de ma spécialité il ya
aussi un certain nombre de personnes qui
sont dans une situation d'incertitude du
fait de la crainte de la coupe de l'aube
une crainte d'une peur mais qui est
légitime --donc qui je pense faut il
faut comprendre et accompagner et c'est
ce que préconise d'ailleurs certains de
mes confrères en santé publique qui dans
le domaine de la promotion de la santé
c'est à dire pour aider les personnes
être plus autonome dans le cadre de leur
santé propose d'accompagner d'être
pédagogue etc c'est ce qu'on fait sur
beaucoup de choses hein déjà alors on
n'est pas très fort en france mais sur
le dépistage sur la vaccination sur
d'autres types d'infections saisonnière
sur le voilà les comportements
favorables à la santé nutrition activité
physique et on prend le temps c'est ce
qu'on fait on essaye d'expliquer de
faire des campagnes mais là on est sur
une crise dont les répercussions peuvent
être si a pas de mesures efficaces des
millions de morts et avec un impact
sanitaire
détestable et sur la santé aussi des
tests donc aujourd'hui on n'a pas trop
le temps d'accompagner ces personnes et
même si je partage l'avis de mes
confrères santé publie siens sur le fait
qu'il faille accompagner plus longtemps
aujourd'hui dans cette can le cas de
cette crise honnêtement je pense que
c'est pas possible mais j'espère qu'on
deviendra une nation de santé publique
qui permettra d'investir sur la
promotion de la santé et donc
d'accompagner mieux les personnes pour
qui est moins de crainte et y répondre
de façon plus efficace à d'éventuelles
autres épidémies messieurs merci en tout
cas d'avoir répondu à nos questions
d'avoir été en direct avec nous françois
cros pense que vous êtes médecin
spécialiste de santé publique et puis
avec nos si jean-marc chipeau
porte-parole de debout la france partie
à bout de messieurs